we are at the 2018 Top Contributor party
for free coke am super excited to be
here with everybody and I'm gonna be
interviewing a lot of these top
contributors to the free coke amp
codebase and community and all of our
infrastructure wow that worked I didn't
actually have to say Sh this is pretty
much a who's who of people who have made
the free cocaine community what it is
today
free coke camp is a global community of
developers who are helping people in
their communities learn to code we have
a ton of free open-source learning
materials ton of Creative Commons
learning material we have a ton of
videos on YouTube we have a ton of
articles on medium we have a ton of
podcast episodes and we have an
incredible curriculum that the entire
community has come together and sculpted
over the past three and a half years and
everything is completely free and
open-source free code camp itself is now
a 501 C 3 non-profit which means that
we're tax exempt and any donations to
free Co camp are tax-deductible
if you happen to have like an employee
matching thing at your office or
something keep that in mind or if you
just happen to have like a killer a year
and you don't want your tax liabilities
to be too big so but we're doing a lot
of exciting things with the donations
from our community we're powering
servers that right now if I were to look
they're probably be four or five hundred
people using the core learning platform
even Saturday night we have millions of
people using free code camp every month
all around the world we have a ton of
people in India we have a ton of people
in Nigeria Bangladesh China has more
than a hundred thousand active campers
and then here in the u.s. of course
Europe Latin America Central America all
over the world Africa even Australia
where I was last month and
Australians are the must chill people I
have to say so we have a lot of people
from all around the world here tonight
and I am going to try to talk to every
single one of you live on stream if
you're cool with it and just talk a
little bit about how you got involved in
free code camp what you're interested in
doing in the coming year what your own
personal goals are for your career oh
and of course why you became part of
this community what what encouraged you
to take your scarce free time and turn
around and invest it into an open-source
project aimed at helping increase
technology literacy I'm very excited to
talk with all you just to give you a
quick recap on how free code camp is
doing we have recently launched the new
curriculum about two months ago and it's
been very popular so far there are a lot
of ways we can continue to improve it
it's never going to be finished it's
always going to be a work in progress
we have tons of study groups around the
world many of whom the leadership of
which is here today and we're going to
talk about the future of those study
groups in ways that we can further
expand them and make it easier for
people to start study groups and
participate in study groups and make it
easier for people to find study groups
and we're we're thinking about ways we
can take the hundreds of people that are
using free kokum at any given moment
and raise awareness if there's a study
group in their City right there on free
cokie org just in time like hey study
group is starting in six hours
would you like to RSVP and also take the
study groups and make them more granular
so you don't have to go you don't have
to commute 30 minutes to get to a study
group after work there's a neighborhood
study group and then there's like a city
level study group that meets once a week
or once a month so we'll have a much
more granular spread out distributed
community where people are learning to
code in smaller groups and coming
together for bigger events we're working
on hackathon tools to make it easier for
us to have
big online hackathons where everybody
can join in and participate wherever
they are in the world our values are of
course being completely free being
convenient for busy people who have kids
who have full-time jobs we're going to
school full-time who have elderly
parents they're taking care of all kinds
of people who are all kinds of busy and
we want to be a resource that
acknowledges it's 20 18 people are
busier than ever there's no sign of
people being less busy in the near
future we want to make it so it's
convenient for all of you to sit down
and get in 30 minutes of coding today an
hour of coding a day maybe just do a
long weekend where you build up an app
over the course of several hours we want
to be here for you all so you can
continue to expand your skills
throughout your in your career as you
progress and as you transition from
field to field and as you get more and
more technical over time thank you all
for everything you're doing it's it's
amazing we were looking at the analytics
for freako camp recently and we are free
cool campus according to similar web
which aggregates all the different
places we're getting something like 15
million visits a month and a lot of that
is to medium a lot of that is to the
core curriculum to the freako camp guide
we've got quite a few people who've
contributed the guide here and a vast
majority of the things to do in the free
cocaine community are powered by
wonderful volunteers like you all want
wonderful contributors so I just want to
have another big round of applause for
everybody here
[Applause]
and I also want to have a round of
applause for all the free coke camp
contributors who couldn't fly out to New
York City I totally understand it's
expensive to fly out and get a hotel in
New York City
and all the contributors who all the
2018 top contributors who are going to
be at the Dublin event next month and
the Hong Kong event in November
I'm here with Mark cross Hinske
and mark is the community organizer for
free coking of Oslo which tell me a
little bit about free coke camp Oslo in
its history
okay so we have an amazing group of okay
amazing group of people and also other
admins very active in Oslo we figured
that mondays are the last competitive
they along the week with other events
which are happening more on the end of
the week and during weekends awesome and
have very many people within the
community over time have have any of
them gotten jobs as developers yeah so
we have like quite you know small
successes in our in our group so you
know besides you know learning learning
purposes of community as ours there are
also a network effect right so some some
people in our community already work in
some companies and we know about you
know some job offers within these
companies or some internships that are
up here so we can we can connect people
between companies and between themselves
to try to collaborate and you know when
you are meeting people a lot of people
are quite shy and
delaying their job application right so
when we see them on our meetups every
week we are pushing them to actually
start applying and pushing them due to
those people who are actually in
industry and and you know make that
connections as soon as possible
all right cheers Megan you've been
involved in freako camp here in New York
City for quite a while could you
describe your involvement so far so when
I first joined free code camp it was in
part because I wanted to learn how to
code I had been doing a little bit of
coding and visual basic already and
wanted to do something that was a little
bit more relevant for you know 2000 and
I also wanted to get to know some new
people because I had just moved to New
York City so it seemed like a good way
to get some learning as well as get to
meet some people so I started going to
the free code camp meetups and working
through the curriculum it really helps
like keep me honest keep me going
through this every time I go to meetups
everybody wants to check on you and see
like how far have you gotten and if
you're still doing the same projects you
were doing two weeks ago it feels a
little bad to say that's other people so
it's a good way to make sure that I was
making progress and as well it's get
help with other people and then as I got
more and more confident also helped to
go and to talk to other people who are
working through the same challenges and
then have to explain the process to them
as well and really solidify that
knowledge so that's how I got sort of
first involved in the meetup so I was
just going as a student and then after a
few months Victoria and Mike were
looking for somebody to run another
meetup on weekends so I volunteered for
that and started running a Saturday
meetup for the last two years but
attendance is sort of mixed because
people have things to do on Saturdays so
no I'm just kind of doing like pop-up
meetups so whenever I have some time
I'll say I'm going to get this place in
two hours if anybody else wants to meet
up there
and we can just code together whatever
we're working on that day deal you're
currently working as a data analyst you
said and a lot of people are kind of
confused about the difference between
doing data analysis and doing actual
data science how would you describe the
difference between the two fields as far
as you understand them so in my
experience I think data science is a
little bit more on the back end doing a
lot of calculations math and writing up
algorithms to try to segment an audience
or something along those lines and data
analysis is here's all this data you
have in front of us now tell us what
this means to a given person and then in
my personal experience it's been more
like that business analysis so if you're
looking at stats for different marketing
campaigns how do you relatively compare
how well each one did and whether you
should continue that campaign
I'm here with a very special contributor
I'm gonna pull your name up just so
everybody can see your Twitter handle
and everything I'm doing this manually
with this amazing tool that Matthew the
a/v extraordinaire creative Ethan
Arrowwood welcome to the live stream and
you hail from Boston you are a student
there an undergraduate student yes so I
am an intern at Microsoft in Cambridge I
am on the commercial software
engineering team and it's a incredible
opportunity on a very unique internship
so rather than working on a specific
product or a specific service that
microsoft offers such as asher or office
I work in it's like almost a hackathon
kind of way where we work with some of
the top as your clients and if they have
any sort of data sets they want analyzed
or worked on or they have problems they
want solutions to or new applications
Microsoft will assemble a crew of
developers from the CSE team and we go
out and we build something really cool
with them for a week or two weeks and
then when we're all done we hand it off
to them we show them how to use it we
provide documentation and a lot of what
we do right gets open-source or at least
we talk about it we were a blog post
about it I'm based in Cambridge like I
said but I actually was here in New York
this past week at the New York office
working on a very incredible project
doing some docker and kubernetes as well
as some react code and it's been the
best internship that ever I could have
ever asked for
you have created a number of videos for
the freako camp YouTube channel which
have done very well and lots of people
have benefited from them and said
positive things about them you've also
written some articles the medium
publication and now you're embarking on
the biggest adventure yet in your free
code camp contributor shift why don't
you tell us a little bit of a bet I
can't wait all right so my biggest
adventure yet is the Python curriculum
it has been a little it's been an idea
since the beginning but it became more
into a fruition about a year ago we
tried it kind of fizzled out but we made
some great you know fundamental
foundational progress and then this year
due to I forget who it was but there was
some incredible Python curriculum that
was uploaded on the YouTube channel and
because of the attention from that we
realized the free code camp community
really wants it wants Python and wants a
in browser experience just like they
currently have for JavaScript and all
the other web tech think web tech things
so right now I am working on the learn
platform of a fork of learn and making
it so it can support Python in the
browser just like you would how we
currently run you know write the code
run the tests get feedback and all that
and earn or earn a certification through
a you know step by step curriculum so
with all of that said I am working hard
on getting that foundation set and then
once that foundation is set we're gonna
take a lot of the aspects of what's
currently there for the JavaScript side
of things and we're going to try to
convert that to Python and then once you
convert those JavaScript fundamentals
and challenges over to Python we will
have the first iteration of a Python
curriculum and then from that there's
some very future-looking ideas like
doing things like more intensive data
science machine learning AI and a lot of
the things that you know a lot of people
are really interested in but don't even
know where to start
Cheers and next we have a very special
guest coming from Carlsbad California
she is a longtime editor of free cocaine
medium publication Toni Toni you have
probably and how many articles you guess
that you may have edited over time maybe
15,000 seems that way yeah it's a lot
it's it's hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of articles that Tony has
edited I'm gonna go ahead and pop her
information here up on the screen for
everybody to check her check her out
Tony tell me a little bit about medium
and what drew you to the platform well
when I first began at free code camp I
was advised to get the medium
publication and I found that all the
articles taught me something and those
that didn't it was okay I still learned
so when I was given the opportunity to
edit for some of my favorite authors I
just had to go for it and I'm glad I did
because I'm always learning every
article that gets published in freako
camp is edited by somebody like tony who
cares about quality and style and wants
to make sure that the article is in the
best possible light what's your workflow
like when you sit down to edit like
what's your what's your environment like
where do you edit just tell us a little
bit like okay I'm gonna go edit now what
happens when you make that decision
first I have to find an article I like I
need to be interested in it that's not
really true sometimes Abby will say hey
someone I need someone to do this
immediately
and if it looks like I can handle it I
like the challenge of English as a
second language because my my skill sets
in grammar and so that makes me feel
good about it but I really like the ones
that just reach out and say hey isn't
this something you're interested in you
know you're doing a react saying that
you want to read about reaction so I'll
decide on the article for whatever
reason and of course we have to put our
avatar on it to let everybody else know
and so once I grab it I try to finish
within 24 hours because I think it's
important the author is waiting for this
you know but also because if I'm you
trust me enough to call on it I need to
go through it so the main thing I look
for is the grammar itself the tenses
whether it happened yesterday or will
happen in the future
basic typos and lates leaks are really
important to me so I'll check every link
in the article to make sure it goes to
where the office says it's going to and
I'll also make sure the JavaScript is
spelled with a capital J and a capital S
that is one that like JavaScript we
think oh and also github right
everybody's follow the GI T uppercase G
ithu B or no uppercase at all right
right that's right you smell directly
nodejs I'm still kind of confused about
so yeah I generally do just uppercase n
OD es Jas and but some people will do
note uppercase J uppercase s I think
angularjs that's actually the proper way
to do it is angularjs whereas most of
the libraries like react GIS you just do
a dot lowercase J S at the end
that's sort of the rule I follow - so
after that I pretty much I hand it over
to Abby who's our final editor and
hopefully she'll say yeah this is great
we publish it without fixing too many
things alright i'm here with jennifer
bland gonna put put your information up
on screen for everybody's benefit i am
so thrilled that you made it out from
atlanta we are so graced by your
presence here have learned so much from
you over the past year year and a half
that you've been contributing at least a
year i don't remember exactly when we've
you know i first talked but your videos
your articles people constantly cite
them as being instrumental in their
efforts to get jobs and to learn more
about programming and just to say
motivated thank you very much i'm
excited to be here excited to be part of
this amazing group of people you know
i'll give you a little bit of background
about myself i used to be a lotus notes
programmer so when I tell people that
always ask people raise your hand if
you've ever used Lotus Notes ever a lot
of people raise their hands and then
like raise your hand if your company
still uses Lotus Notes nobody does and
that explains why I actually got out of
programming many many years ago and I
started working on an internet marketing
business on the side and it grew and I
retired at the age of 51 and I was
retired for about a year and a half and
one day walked into Barnes and Noble
picked up a book on JavaScript
programming on the clearance rack spent
a month working through it learning it
and then it was like stay unemployed
passion for programming and that passion
for programming ran one out and I
decided to become unemployed
I mean unretired and go back into work
and I did a coding boot camp that is so
prevalent today and after my coding boot
camp I graduated
got a job working at CNN in Atlanta and
that's when I started working with free
code camp because you know you could
only learn so much in three months and a
coding bootcamp and I wanted to greatly
improve my cutting skills and so I'd
literally in six months when they you
have the original curriculum went
through and did every one of those
certificates got to work on one of the
nonprofit organizations for you know for
crimes against women and that was a
great experience for doing that and now
what I like to do is be able to get back
and contribute to others you've spent a
lot of time and energy specifically
helping people with the somewhat jarring
and unpredictable job application
process and I think one of the things
that surprises people the most when they
go ahead and apply for jobs is just that
they have to apply for a lot of jobs and
it's a pretty it's in the skills you
employ in a job interview are very
different from what you would employ and
you're actually doing the job due to the
way that the job processes application
process is involved can you talk a
little bit about the things that you
think are if you had just a few
high-level tips for people when they're
applying for jobs absolutely
the first tip that I would give people
even if you have some of the skill sets
they list in a job description but not
all of them apply you don't need to have
all of them apply every job that I've
had since I came out of a cutting boot
camp I didn't have a hundred percent of
the skill sets but I still got the job
number two would be even if you don't
think that you have the skill set still
apply and then get in get your foot in
the door and talk to somebody and if you
get a rejection from an interview write
them back and do say something like I
understand why you rejected me but I
think you might
to reconsider because I can do this and
if you show that that initiative that
drive that motivation a lot of companies
will will take a second chance and look
at you from that perspective but the
other thing is I would encourage people
to also go out and start distinguishing
themselves from others you know because
like my coding bootcamp we had you know
20 people in my class 21 people in my
class 21 people out interviewing for
jobs we all have the exact same skills
we went through the same three-month
training camp the people that were
writing articles or doing things above
and beyond that and they could put that
on their resume we're the first people
to get hired out of that coding boot
camp so it's your future it's your
career you can take control of it and be
able to do something on the side like
that where you know the like the live
streaming you know I learning how to
program I make mistakes do live
streaming people will reach out to you
write an article about something people
will reach out to you I've I've had
people that have come up to me in
meetings and I mean it at conferences
and just say I just want to shake your
hand I follow you on twitter I read your
stuff and I'm like I don't know who
these people are but they know who I am
because of what I've done so then those
are the the recommendations that I would
give to people that's that's a great
advice Jennifer about 15% of the people
in the free code camp community the
youth free code camps learning platform
and are transitioning into developer
jobs our 45 and older here's someone who
in her 50s did learn an entirely new
additional skill set
granted you already knew Lotus Notes
programming and things like that but I
imagine you had to learn a lot of new
stuff too yep
what would be some advice for people who
are in their 40s 50 60s who are planning
to transition who may feel discouraged
by the you know the
perception in many cases that it's
harder for people to get into tech if
they're doing it as a second or third
career that's that's a very good
question because I did a tendon cutting
boot camp when I was 51 I actually
turned 52 in the middle of that
three-month coding boot camp I would
encourage everybody to do it you're
never too old to start to learn to get
into tack and a lot of people that are
older or discouraged because they're
like I'm too old that you know I don't
know this and I'm but here's my take on
that for somebody that's older you've
got decades of life experiences business
experiences that people in their 20s or
30s aren't going to have for 20 or 30
years now and even if you are learning
to program you're going to have business
experience that you can apply to any
project that you're working on in a
company and that is invaluable to any
company to have because if you're
thinking about coming out with a new
product or a new app or something like
that you're going to be able to provide
input and direction because of that
experience that nobody else has and then
because of that you're gonna end up
producing a better product a better
quality app you know something like that
and it's just become better because of
that experience that you're going to be
able to offer up to potential employers
thank you again Jennifer
mr. Stuart Taylor coming to us from
Bally castle Stuart has been a prolific
contributor to freako camp if you've
used the freako camp curriculum in the
past two months it's running on the
learn application that Stuart led the
creation of Stewart has re are connected
free Co camps learning platform
completely to be a static application
and to interact with an API and it's
extremely fast it's all react it's a
single page app it'll lazy load
challenges if they haven't already been
loaded when you're using it but as a
result it's faster than ever it's
smoother than ever Stewart also created
the free code camp guide which is an
incredibly important part of free code
camp
it's a lay person accessible version of
like the Mozilla developer Network would
be a good way to describe it and we have
4,000 plus articles there on all range
of topics
you know C++ sequel of course JavaScript
and and little articles on pretty much
every single challenge on the free
cocaine curriculum many Witcher stubs
and we welcome your help flushing those
stubs out so that people can have like
kind of a corresponding hint with
spoilers and things like that in case
they get stuck kind of challenge but
Stewart has been building all these
things he's been doing so much exciting
stuff to to help us like simplify the
DevOps flow improve site reliability you
name it
that's Stewart and his recent
contributions to free code camp Stewart
now works full-time for free code camp
he is the senior most developer on our
team at this point he touches pretty
much every aspect of free code camp
he even has production access to the
database in case he wants to pull a get
lab and wipe out of days where the data
I'm just just kidding if you have an or
forget lab work we love that you're
post-mortal on that get lab friends so
I've been talking a lot about Stewart
I'm gonna let Stewart tell you a little
bit about his background and how he came
to be a developer all right hi how you
doing
so I say my working life started out I
was was in the military in there for
eight years once I'm finished I I
started work for a telecoms company
building fiber optic network so I built
the internet around where I live it's
only a small country of 1.8 million
people going everyone fast internet and
I went to being a stay-at-home dad and
in that time I thought well my wife she
had a business and she needed a website
so we went to Squarespace and just use
their website builder a bit or website
it's fantastic worked great until we
decided to change the header image on
the front page now originally there was
a picture of a woman my wife doesn't an
aesthetics business so the original
image was a woman on the left-hand side
and we had the business name and a call
to action but on the right hand side we
got some new images and the imagery were
wanted on their header was the one was
on the right hand side we didn't want
the title and the call-to-action button
over her face we want to move across the
other side so I rang Square Spanish said
hey how can I get the site title and
this little button over to the other
side of the page and the person on the
phone said that you can't do it with it
it's not possible
so I thought that doesn't sound quite
right so I went on there too now giggled
around and I thought well how can I move
a button to this side of a page on a
website and found a little stuck over
low thing and typed in some CSS didn't
know what that was tightening a word but
alright that was pretty cool well know
what else I can do what can I get this
so if you scroll down the page is
another image that comes in is what can
I get that just slide in like all the
other cool websites out there no clue
how to do it so how do I make an image
slide in from side of the page and a
website Stack Overflow something about
jQuery copy and paste this code all
right worked brilliant all the way else
I can do so I went searching around and
found some courses on like coke Adam II
and all that and work through a few of
them didn't quite like too much of it
somehow found free coke am i started
working through their curricula yeah
this works for me and this is really
easily HTML so if I have seen this
before I'll bash that out brilliant
right JavaScript is that like jQuery I
don't know but carry on going and it's
all got to the point where I was
comfortable with what I was doing and I
thought was this this freako camp they
give back to the community as a whole is
wondering how can I make I cannot how
can I help them that's where I found
github and when looking through all the
issues and I found an issue where there
was a diagram of it was describing some
sort of class name on a bootstrap button
and there was a typo on the image and
the issue was to change the image so
there would have been better if it was
just code if you just have a button on
the screen and have
the snippet of what that code is for the
button and I managed to get that
implemented and after a bit of - in
frame we've got a pull request opened
and I got it merged and it was the
greatest feeling in the world
somebody sort of verified my ability to
code something you know so like somebody
Haddix said like yeah this is good
enough for freako camp and it was
accepted
there's pushed live and it was just
amazing alright well what else can I do
and that sort of pattern went on from
what else can I do how do we do that
right that's how I've managed to do it
alright somebody said it's good enough
so what else could sort of snowball
effectively to where I was implementing
features in react I mean six months
before that was happening know what
react was I was getting featured
implemented and I was fixing bugs and it
turns out then that somebody wanted to
hire me to do it something I was doing
for a hobby and of course I said yeah
alright
and then Here I am today knocking code
out all over the place
extending the reach of freako comp
making it easier for people to get there
and start learning the way I did bill
doesn't need much of an introduction if
you've read the pre-cooking at media
publication you've almost certainly seen
him on there he is prolific he's done
quite a few podcast episodes as well and
he's just an extremely experienced
knowledgeable developer can work coding
for more than 20 years
done high-profile projects for lots of
different corporations and government
agencies around Canada bill welcome
thank you so much and no pressure that's
a heck of an introduction
thanks Quincey well you're somebody whom
I look up to as a mentor I've learned so
many software engineering best practices
from you what are some areas of software
engineering that you would say are the
most interesting for you that you really
want to drill down and continue to
specialize and as your career progresses
so one of the things that I come across
a lot is the notion so just for
background for the sake of background
and sorry I'm going to talk for a second
now say hey I never have a problem talk
so what I do is I'm a freelance
consultant and so oftentimes I airdrop
into an organization when most of their
apps are like seven to ten two more
years old and they've got so much
technical debt that the the engineering
team the dev team is spending most of
their time you know dealing with that
technical debt like 80 90 percent of the
resources are being spent on that and
the business side of the house or the
clients in the in there are really
frustrated because they can't get much
value out of this dev team so they're
paying all this money for all these
engineers and they're not really getting
much out of it because the engineers are
really busy you know living with the
hell that they've created for themselves
right
and there are some really common things
that I see from client defined to client
that contribute to that around how how
those apps were were built in the first
place
and and how they were you know basically
it's a problem of architecture and so
that's an area that I'm you know as I
get more and more experienced I think
that's a really key vital thing and I
don't think that you know I don't know
that that that's the first thing you're
gonna learn is appropriate you're come
in a free code camp and you know you
haven't written a lick of JavaScript
that's probably not the first thing you
should focus on but as as people come
into organizations and and they're you
know getting their first first job or
they're in their first year these are
the kinds of things that I want to
figure out how to help people learn and
understand and so it really comes down
to like how how you architect your
application and and the common one of
the most common things is the the tight
coupling of business logic integration
logic and third-party dependencies so
you've got some framework that's like
you know some framework or library
that's like the the hot thing of the of
the moment and then you've got some some
integration of your dependencies and
you've got all your business logic and
it's one kind of ball of mud that's all
really tightly coupled together so I see
that over and over and over and over and
over again and then what happens is you
know fast forward several years that
whatever framework or library it was is
like no longer the hotness and in fact
it's virtually abandoned and full of
security holes the business logic that
you have in there is not well documented
no one understands it no one knows what
to do with it and nobody wants to touch
the thing because they're like well if
we touch this we break like the universe
and so we don't know what to do and so
so trying to teach people how to tackle
and solve those problems is what I'm
becoming more and more interested in
have it I think a few ways into it but I
still haven't like fully wrap my mind
around it sorry that's like a super long
detail thanks for - yeah and you have a
newsletter dev mastery that often delves
into a lot of these more advanced I
would take considerations in
architecture decisions and and how to
prevent the kind of toxic technical debt
as opposed to the more manageable thank
you for that right yeah I mean you're
never gonna be like that free our
technical debt free but if you you know
if you think about an organization that
if you kind of zoom out and think about
like okay they're pouring money they're
investing money into like their dev team
and less and less of that money is going
to like generating new value because
it's all being spent on like dealing
with the craft of the past that that's a
bad scenario right so yeah so I put this
newsletter and that you can get from dev
mastery comm that I send out as often as
I can when I have time and these are
some of the types of things that I like
to tackle so that and then you know just
articles that I find interesting topics
that I find interesting that I think
would be will be helpful to others at
pretty much at all levels I think but
you really people in the first the
feedback that I get is people in the
first sort of five years of their career
from like zero to five years tends to be
sort of the sweet spot for the stuff
that I put out you know again if it's
like if you've written your first line
of code yesterday
it might not be for you yet but soon
it'll be for you soon and then you know
if you just got your first job for sure
I'm gonna hit you with stuff that you
you need to start thinking about and so
yeah so that's been so Raphael has been
a major contributor to the free cocaine
wiki which was a precursor to the free
coke amp guide if you had a guide that
free cooking better work there's a good
chance that some of the articles you'll
read there were authored by none other
than Raphael originally Raphael tell us
a little bit about yourself well I am
really from the Dominican Republic can
here 2005 looking for software engineer
career but my translations were in that
used so I went for computer science
which was closest and from there I
finished school I start applying for
jobs you know a lot of emails interviews
ain't nothing happening so I decide I
will go and study something else and I
started doing let me check Python or
some foreign language see there were a
lot of jobs looking for those skills and
checking different languages signing up
with JavaScript and I said this is my
language I can use in the front end
occasion the back end since like if I
learned this I'll be good anywhere I go
so I started studying that I discovered
free cocaine by saying boot camp seems
to be where everybody's doing to learn
fast
get a job in this is what I named my new
at the time my song was very young like
3
so I instill in my family I have a kid I
finished school I'm trying to get a job
soon aim free cook what's the place I
said I'm gonna do these this looks
promising I'm gonna do it and I started
working on the challenges and because I
have bad memory I don't trust my own
memory I decide let me take notes but
let me take good notes not like I did
back in high school right so you
essentially took your notes on all the
challenges and that formed the basis of
the wiki and I remember approaching you
two years ago two and a half years ago
and you had these elaborate notes with
your solutions and everything on all
these free coke camp channel challenges
and we use that as the basis for the
wiki man it's been real so Joe hails
from Norfolk Virginia where he has been
leading the free cooking of study group
yes tell us a little bit about that well
I think it was 2015 when you originally
made the call when I first found them
free code camp it was probably in I
think he put out the call in like
October or November of 2015 I was when I
found freaking was like July of 2015 and
I was I was broke I was a has-been a
salesman for a start-up and I lost my
job doing that and I wasn't making very
good money of that anyway so I was a
janitor at night and so I had had it
being broke I was making about $800 a
month at that point and I just had said
I really want to learn how to code I'm
tired of I'm tired of just kind of all
my programming friends were traveling
and they're having good lives and their
social media feeds made them look very
happy and I was not so one so one night
you know everybody told me I needed to
learn JavaScript so I typed in cheap
JavaScript resource or cheap JavaScript
coding camp or something like that
because all the boot camps at the time
were costing 10 15 grand and
and I didn't have that and I found free
cocaine and so it was about 2:00 in the
morning as is my want because I don't
sleep very much and I said oh it's how I
learned HTML in a night and I said
there's something to this and I became
really passionate about it because I was
learning something for free I I realized
I was on the path that was gonna do well
and all I had to do was put it into time
I didn't have the brainpower but kind of
like lifting weights or doing anything
else you just got to put in the time you
got to put in the work and so when the
call came out for them you for us to
start up like a local meet up I was like
guess we need to do this and there was
one already unfortunate be towards the
city right next to Norfolk but nobody
was going to it and I said well I have a
lot of coding friends I can ask them to
be speakers I'm sure they would want to
contribute open-source was kind of a new
idea to me didn't know what it was it's
like so how do you make money on this
how do you how do you make a living at
doing this and what I didn't realize is
that as you build a community as you
build a reputation and as you help
others that that follows that follows
suit so this was my way of a newbie
coder not knowing how to teach still
contributing and giving people who are
just like me content that was going to
be good and useful for them if they
wanted to continue down that path this
is Victoria Carey Olek all right
Keri Olek and she is actually the woman
who created the free coke camp NYC
Facebook group back in the day there was
a day when there was not a New York City
group like one of the most popular
cities in the world right so Victoria
thank you so much for joining us here
tell us a little bit about your history
with free coke camera well when I
initially fit went into free code camp I
was looking for JavaScript help I had
just left a job I was doing freelancing
and while everybody was okay with HTML
CSS they wanted to have JavaScript and
while I was familiar with copy/paste use
I wonder how it worked and found freako
camp and started doing the challenges
one of the challenges that popped up was
hey if there's not a FB group and free
code and for free cocaine blonde you
make it I'm like okay let's check then
we had a group because I created that as
for as people started joining they were
saying let's all meet up let's all meet
up I'm like okay we're it's good we had
a couple people who have recently moved
or had recently moved at that time
wanted to meet up but nobody actually
wanted to make the meetup so what ended
up happening was I eventually got a
couple of volunteers to come together to
be leaders and we put together an idea
for a coffee in code which we had run
across on the free code camp group that
Quincy was running at the time running
I'm not even sure but we great thing
copying code read agree make it a short
thing meet everybody we put that
together and at each of those meetings
it kind of grew and grew and grew and we
ended up meeting some people like Megan
like Michael you probably see later
who ended up becoming our new leaders
and have been holding the fort together
for the last three years basically every
so often we could get together and try
to do something else like I tried to
have a leader summit but then then that
kind of fell through
so I would like to actually get more
leaders at some point so if you're out
there and you want to do something in
New York City talk to me
you got my information come talk to me
because I want you to be a leader so
that we can have one group day studying
every day of the week as long as we can
okay come on in thank you so much
Victoria Mike tell us a little bit about
your experience venturing into software
development so far oh wow
software development well the the thing
is that I sort of was a passion since
childhood part of it anyway not web
development but software development in
programming is so I I've kind of cheated
I didn't start from Ground Zero
I started at probably when I was like 12
writing C++ code and tinkering around
with that I had no idea that was gonna
bring me anywhere in life that was
literally just a hobby people play with
trains I play with programs then wave
after many years later I was sitting in
New York after travelling a while and I
didn't have a job I didn't have anything
to do and I was just I randomly stumbled
upon a meetup group which was run by
Victoria for freako camp and I found the
curriculum and I really liked how it was
structured just like one two three for
me web developer whatever because I
couldn't find before this website I
really could not find any concise
resources I mean there was stuff you
know coke atom II whatever there was
things that are available but they were
kind of disjoint it or they were in the
form of just like here's a tutorial and
then you're done here it was like 1 2 3
non-profit projects all of that and it
felt like I felt like exactly what I was
looking for that couldn't find before so
what would be the single like if you had
a single thing that you give as advice
for people who want to get into
freelancing who've been working through
the free cocaine curriculum or have been
just building projects on their own for
a while and really want to start making
some monies of freelancer what would be
your single best advice for them
you are the expert chances are your
client knows a lot less than you do
about what he's asking you to do this is
why he's hiring you so you are the
expert and in that role this is this is
a people position almost it's your job
to convince the client that you can do
what's best for them and I guess I want
to say like they say in a joke they are
more afraid of you than you are of them
so that's you don't need to be ashamed
you don't need to be afraid
whatever you think you don't know and we
all struggle with this all the time we
all struggle with the the so called the
impostor syndrome they know a lot less
and they're coming to you for advice and
your job is to give them that advice if
you're trying to get into freelancing
just do it just start now start small
don't don't worry about even if you put
an ad out there and the first person you
get is just not the kind of client you
would want I mean there are different
circumstances keep trying and just grab
that first so after that first one that
first assignment whether it's just do
this one page for I'm not gonna get I
want to name actual money figures but
here's just do this one page for not
very much money just do it this is when
you get your first kind of grasp of the
skills that you possess you realize what
you can do what you can do well yeah so
I'm here with two amazing people
Johnny Bissell and and my niece Gary
thank you so much gentlemen for flying
out from your respective cities first
tell us a little bit about yourself
Johnny hi everyone I'm Johnny Bissell I
was a c-sharp the vb.net developer
seven years with a knowledge of SQL what
I found was was working on web forms and
quite old technology and I really wanted
to learn new things like node and
MongoDB and one of the guys I was
working with recommended free code camp
so I thought yeah I'll give it a try and
that was about two and a bit years ago
and I'm still plodding along through the
masse of course but don't let that put
you off it's very good so the the goal
is to upscale basically with new
technologies and get more relevant up
today work and then along the ride I've
spent a lot of time on the forum and the
chat rooms helping out new beginners
which is also aided mine learning
process so it's been great
and the course is improved over the
years and I've made lots of friends I
encourage people to network and pair
program and meet other developers
because it's difficult to motivate
yourself doing stuff just purely on ease
on yourself so yeah any more questions
yeah
first let's hear from money shhhhh thank
you so much for joining us thank you
thanks for having me here my name is
Manish I am
a grad student in you see since the
University of Cincinnati in Ohio I did
my engineering from India and computer
science and after that I decided to get
a higher higher degree in computer
science so I join you see since then
it's been a good journey I've started
getting getting into more more into
software development starting with Java
and then recently I came across I
decided to get into JavaScript because
what's more important for me is to build
something and it's the same happening
right in front of me that's that's where
javascript is more powerful than Java
because we don't need a lot of things to
set it up you can do it immediately with
JavaScript just open your browser write
your code and you're done
so that's how I got into JavaScript and
that's how I got into free code camp
actually because when I was learning
JavaScript there were just tutorials
everywhere you read read read and
there's no coding exercises or
challenges that's where free code camp
was helpful because I saw there were a
series of code challenges your elearn
you write you see your code if it
doesn't pass you ask for help and that's
how you learn I mean with free code camp
for about two years now two three years
now it's it's been a pretty good journey
so far I used to hang around in the help
chat rooms me and there was one more
camper recall Steven James I mean he's a
legend in these chat rooms so it was fun
hanging around there
and yeah hope to continue more in this
area and I'm hoping that some of the
people watching this right now will
contribute to the community and will
make the list of very elite capable
people who are helping drive this
community forward and helping set the
course for so many people who want to
become developers and who want to become
more technical and break in to break
into tech so thank you both gentlemen
and thank you everybody for watching
these interviews I think we're gonna do
quick closing I didn't get a chance to
interview everybody I think I was
interviewing people for like three hours
straight I am so thrilled that everybody
came and freako camp is early days we
are rapidly growing in terms of people
in the community the amount of things
out there that we're creating for other
people to learn from the amount of
Rockstar developers and teachers that
are that are coming through freako camp
so we want to absolutely continue to
facilitate as many people as possible
who want to learn to code because my
firm belief is that just like you had to
learn to read when a point type slides
and things like that in the 90s if you
wanted to continue to work as a
knowledge worker now you need to learn
to code and regardless of how your job
may seem like oh I don't necessarily see
where coding would be directly
applicable to this I think it will be
sooner or later because what we're
seeing is jobs are the expectations are
just getting higher and higher for your
understanding of technology to be able
to take these mainframes that we carry
around in our pockets and put them to
work for us because most of the work in
society today is done not by humans but
by robots and there's a very small
category of people who are telling those
robots what to do but we want everybody
to be able to tell those robots what to
do we want to have everybody empowered
with the
rapidly exploding computational power
that is falling in price every year that
we can all put to work so that everybody
is you know a Tony Stark like superhuman
who can just command the world around
them and we'll get there very soon and
so I'm optimistic that by helping more
people become comfortable with
technology and learn how to code and
learn how to work with databases and use
all these tools at our disposal we'll be
able to you know expedite the the
arrival of the singularity like
post-scarcity society where everybody's
just super enriched and everybody is
able to live lives of leisure and lives
of mind so what we're gonna absolutely
get there and everybody in this room is
helping us get there faster so thank you
[Applause]
and for everybody who's watching this
again I hope some of these amazing
people have inspired you to get involved
in the developer community and to
contribute to open source and to turn
around and teach all the things that
you're learning and to to be utterly
voracious and relentless in your
personal development